2014 a group of astronomers are studying
the Kuiper belt a vast band of icy
asteroids that sits way way outside the
orbit of Neptune most of these objects
move in a neat circular formation around
the sign but the astronomers are puzzled
by a small group that appears to break
the rules
swinging far outside the main belt on
wild extended orbits something sitting
far outside the Kuiper belt seems to be
pulling these asteroids out of line
something the size of a giant planet
when we saw these alignments of all
these objects out there we thought oh hi
everybody's going to say there's a
planet we have to very strongly prove
there's not a planet because of course
we all know there's not another planet
out there that's ridiculous
[Music]
Mike asks his colleague konstantin
batygin to run a computer simulation to
see what effect a ninth planet should
have on the Kuiper belt stunningly the
simulation predicts elongated orbits
identical to the ones already observed
but the simulation also spits out a
surprise there should be a second set of
rogue orbits that are perpendicular to
the first set if Mike can locate these
weird predicted objects inside the
Kuiper belt planet 9 is almost certainly
real I remember sitting back and and
thinking ok we're going to right now
plot the data the real observational
data on top of the model and Mike said
if these two match up my jaw is just
gonna drop to the floor the theory says
they should be right here and right here
and I did the calculations very quickly
to see where they were and brought them
up and there they are 1 2 3 4 5 right on
these lines exactly where we predicted
they should be the moment we saw this we
went from cautious to holy cow this
really is there we have to make sure to
tell everybody right away because it's
actually real Mike and Konstantin had
unlocked the solar system's greatest
secret planet 9 was almost certainly
real and it had to be huge perhaps 10
times the mass of Earth we're not
talking about something like our moon or
Pluto we're talking about something that
is literally planet sized and we're
seeing its gravitational wake affecting
these other objects the idea that there
could be a giant planet that we'd never
seen is something I think most of people
wouldn't have bet on but the evidence is
remarkable
you